- [Sal] Which of the
following is the graph of a
function F such that F
of X is equal to zero
for exactly two values of X
between negative five and five?
So let's see, in all
of them they've plotted
where X equals negative
five and X equals five.
F of X needs to be equal
to zero for two values of X
between negative five and five.
So this function right over
here, this never gets to zero.
In order to get to zero
it needs to intersect,
it needs to touch on the
x-axis at some point.
This one stays positive the whole time.
Notice all the values for
this X right over here,
F of X, it's a positive value.
For this value of X right over here,
F of X is a positive value,
so rule that one out.
This one equals zero here, here and here.
So it equals zero three
times, for exactly three
values of X between
negative five and five,
but they said exactly two values,
so we'll rule that one out.
This one is right at
positive five, you could say
it's at one value if we
include the two boundary points
right over here, but we said exactly two.
This is kind of the other
side of it where we're
only at negative five,
we need to be two times,
so rule that one out.
This one, we intersect the
x-axis exactly two times.
F of X is equal to zero
for this value of X,
F of X is equal to zero and F
of X is zero right over there.
So that's...
This is our choice.
Another thing that could
have looked like that,
maybe if it looked something like that.
We would've had F of X
equal zero there and there.
Either way, we pick D.